Wow thank you very much welcome it's
it's an honor to be back here in
Philadelphia and and particularly an
honor to be here at the Free Library of
Philadelphia what a great institution
this is I I understand that the the
drone issue now has a very serious local
connection here in Pennsylvania with the
the the decommission will Grove Air
Force Base is going to be converted into
a drone command and control center and
you know I know guys who are drone
pilots they get very offended when you
say that they're unmanned aircraft but
just so people understand I'm sure many
of you have been working on this issue
here locally know how this works but you
have individuals who are in trailers or
in command centers one of them is in in
the southwest of the United States and
they drive to work every day and they
get into the into the box where they're
operating these aircraft half a world
away over the in skies of Pakistan or
Yemen and and they engage in warfare
where they're playing what is
essentially a video game in their
trailer or their command center but the
people that are being targeted on the
ground are real people that are being
killed and at this particular base where
I know a drone pilot told me that when
he gets into his car and he drives off
the base after having been involved with
operations sometimes lethal sometimes
surveillance and there's a sign when
he's leaving that says buckle up this is
the most dangerous part of your day
meaning he has a greater likelihood of
getting hit in a car accident than he
does of being killed even though he's
involved with bombing other countries
around the world and drones have been a
component of what the Obama
administration calls its
counterterrorism strategy there's been a
dramatic escalation of the use of drones
to strike not just in Pakistan but also
in Yemen occasionally in Somalia the
u.s. is under President Obama very much
building up its covert action
capabilities on the African continent in
fact when I was on the air in the
airport on my way here I ran into a
young guy he said he was going for
deployment said where are you going he
said oh I'm going to a place called
Djibouti and and the u.s. of course
has taken over an old French military
base they're called Camp Lemonnier and
out of that base is the conventional US
military under the auspices of AFRICOM
the us-africa command but there's also
CIA paramilitaries and elite commandos
from the Joint Special Operations
Command that used it as a staging ground
to run operations into Somalia and
elsewhere they trained forces from
Ethiopia Uganda and Burundi the u.s. is
contemplating building another drone
base around Mali where they're going to
be targeting a group called al-qaeda in
the Islamic Maghreb you also have a base
in Ethiopia and a relatively new base
across the water on the Arabian
Peninsula in Saudi Arabia and and I
think we're going to see an
intensification of covert u.s. action
certainly in Africa and where we've
already seen it happen in Yemen we're
living in a moment where we have a
popular Democratic president who is a
constitutional lawyer by trade and
training who won the Nobel Peace Prize
and who campaigned on a multiple pledges
to reverse the excesses and abuses of
the Bush era said he was going to close
Guantanamo it's going to end torture was
going to shut down the CIA so-called
black sites around the world but what's
happened under this popular Democratic
president who won the Nobel Peace Prize
is that many of the most egregious
aspects of the apparatus that was built
by built up by Bush and Cheney and their
cohort have been intensified or
continued some of them have been
rebranded and there's an attempt to
legitimize policies that I think many
liberals would have opposed if John
McCain had won that election but because
it's President Obama he's getting a free
pass you know we don't we don't have
anything even vaguely resembling a
credible challenge to these policies in
the Congress because the Democrats have
have checked their conscience at the
door and they're sitting out these two
terms of Obama when it comes to asking
key questions about how far we've come
since 9/11 you know that in the in the
week after September 11th and the week
after those attacks Congress passed a
bill called the authorization
the use of military force the AUMF and
basically what that did is it gave a
blank check to the Bush administration
to wage a global borderless war and it
authorized the u.s. to send forces in to
any country that it deemed had a
connection to al-qaeda or the attack the
9/11 attacks and that they could hunt
down any individuals who were even
tangentially connected to the 9/11
attacks that is still the law that
President Obama and his administration
cite when they are bombing people in
Yemen in some cases targeting
individuals who were toddlers on 9/11
the law was written to target the people
responsible for 9/11 how was a toddler
responsible for 9/11 how are they still
using that law it was a blank check and
it's still being used to this day now
there's discussion about rewriting it to
make it permanent President Obama said
in his second inauguration his second
inaugural address that he didn't want
the the u.s. to live in a state of
perpetual war but his policies indicate
that he wants the exact opposite that
that's exactly what he wants he wants
the u.s. to be in a perpetual state of
war there was only one member of
Congress that voted against the AUMF
imagine what that must have been like we
all remember what it was like in those
days after 9/11 the fear and hysteria
gripping the country and and and it was
this one member of Congress barbara Lee
of California and she stood up III I
think young people should in particular
we all of us but young people in
particular should watch that speech and
you can find it on online because
barbara Lee was trembling when she gave
that speech imagine the courage that
that took to stand up and what she said
in her speeches is that we cannot use
these attacks to engage in retaliation
across the globe and and and engage in
actions that are going to undermine our
democratic principles and we cannot wage
a war that doesn't have an endgame and
you know what Barbara Lee was right she
was so prophetic in her vision in the
same way that russ feingold when he was
the lone senator to vote against the
patriot act saw something that that so
many of their colleagues on Capitol Hill
either were too blind to notice or or
willfully chose to embrace a rollback a
massive rollback of our civil liberties
you see to have the temerity or the
courage to ask tough questions at a time
when there's calls for mob violence
takes real backbone it takes real
courage and we're in one of those
moments today where we have this popular
Democratic president who won the Nobel
Peace Prize it's easy to oppose policies
when you have cartoonish villains like
Dick Cheney you know in control and
who's you know the the I do actually
imagine him in his lair plotting the
destruction of the world for Halliburton
stocks to go up and I'm only slightly
kidding but but but when you when you
have the actual courage to stand up and
say that the same principles that
applied when those guys were in power
when Bush and Cheney were in power apply
when President Obama is empowered that
that actually is where your principles
are tested and so we have an expansion
of the drone strikes we have the use of
secret prisons not being run by the CIA
but being run by other governments and
their human rights abusing forces and
we're shipping prisoners off to be
tortured in secret prisons in countries
like Somalia in the basement of its
national security service and I I
documented this when I travel to
Mogadishu so so here's change under
President Obama we close the CIA's black
sites in Poland and Thailand but then we
start using Somalia's gulag where we are
interrogating prisoners we have CIA
operatives and military intelligence
interrogating prisoners some of whom who
have been snatched off the streets of
third countries in one case I documented
a young guy from Kenya who was snatched
out of his home taken to Wilson Airport
shackled and hooded and then flown to
Somalia where he was put in this bed bug
infested underground prison with no
access to light no access to the outside
world no access to lawyers and could not
tell his family where he'd been taken
that action happened under President
Obama and when I called the US
government for comment they said yeah
that's that sounds right and they said
well why wouldn't we why wouldn't we do
that it's natural that we would want to
cooperate with the Somalian Kenyan
authorities in the fight against
terrorism I think most Americans were
under the impression when Obama issued
the three executive orders that he did a
couple of days into his administration
that he was going to be dismantling it
not
rebranding it and recasting it as a more
legitimate form of running the same
program but that's largely what's
happened renditions continue under
President Obama assassination has been
normalized as a central component not as
though we haven't had that history
before in this country but it's been
normalized by this president as a
central component of what's called
America's national security policy I
think that many liberals would have been
up in arms if John McCain had tried to
say assert the right to kill American
citizens without charging them with a
crime when they're not on an active
battlefield shooting against American
soldiers but when President Obama did it
and there were three US citizens killed
in a two-week period in the fall of 2011
there were two responses in Washington
silence or enthusiastic support Hillary
Clinton sounded exactly like John McCain
in her statements that she issued 70%
according to one poll a year and a half
or so ago 70 percent of self-identified
liberals said that they support drone
strikes and that their support for those
strikes dropped only negligibly when the
target in question was an American
citizen you see I think we're at a
moment where we've crossed a line and
it's going to be very very difficult to
roll it back particularly when there's
no credible opposition or even credible
questioners of the policy on Capitol
Hill we recently had hearings two sets
of hearings on on drone strikes and
targeted killing and one of these
hearings there was a young Yemeni named
Fidel mostly me I know this guy I'd met
him in Yemen he's a very impressive
young man and he's invited to testify in
front of the US Senate six days before
he came to the US to testify his
family's village in Yemen had been
bombed in a drone strike and and and he
live tweeted the text messages that he
was getting from his relatives who were
near the scene and then he comes in
front of the US Congress and we had this
opportunity to have someone who could
explain firsthand what the impact of
those kinds of strikes would be not just
for Yemen's stability but for our own
what what happens to people when their
family members get killed in a drone
strike when the intelligence turned out
to be bad in oops we actually killed a
group of teenagers because we had
categorized them as military age males
and he gave a very eloquent
statement in front of the US Senate and
then for the next two hours instead of
asking him questions relevant questions
Democratic and Republican senators alike
asked three academics who were sitting
next to him who could have walked to
Congress any day of the week theoretical
questions they spent endless minutes
discussing whether we should be
referring to it as a drone or a UAV and
you've got a Yemeni who's village had
just been bombed who could have answered
many questions and told us a lot about
the impact that the strikes are having
so I don't put all of this on President
Obama I put a lot of this also on the
Congress the other thing is that there's
a culture in Washington where when
military figures or CIA officials go to
Capitol Hill Congress members want to
know are we winning which is such a
false question are we winning and then
they wanted they wanted to have metrics
to define it and so body count that's
become the the way that we define
victory how many terrorists have we
killed you know we're doing something in
Yemen and Pakistan now called signature
strikes there are two kinds of basic two
kinds of drone strikes one is a
personality strike where you have a
known individual and and you've decided
that you're going to take him out so I'm
in al-zawahiri's you know the nominal
head of al-qaeda now and in the
aftermath of bin Laden's demise he's a
signature he's a personality strike if
the u.s. finds him and they want to kill
him they take him out or b'stilla
Massoud who was one of the leaders of of
the Pakistani Taliban who was killed
madrone strike in 2009 but then we're
also doing these things called signature
strikes which is at certain regions of
Pakistan and Yemen have been determined
to be hostile zones and any military age
males in those areas who have even a
remote connection to someone that the US
has flagged as a potential terrorist
maybe they went to the same mosque as
them maybe they delivered food to a
certain house maybe they were on a phone
call with someone if that if that
individual is in a group of other
military age males u.s. policy is to
assume that they are terrorists and
preemptively kill them it's like some
grotesque form of pre-crime like the
movie Minority Report we are killing
people intentionally this is important
to listen to each detail this we are
killing people intentionally whose
identities we do not know and against
whom we may not even possess
intelligence that they're involved with
criminal or
plots think think about what that means
it's that's murder that is murder when
you are saying we're going to just say
that this group of young men because of
their age and where they live and
because somebody had been on the phone
with somebody that we think is a
terrorist that we're going to just say
that they are terrorists and killed them
you know I've been on the ground
examining the aftermath of these strikes
not just the drone strikes but the
cruise missile strikes and the night
raids done by special operations forces
and I've come to the firm belief that
that the United States is now creating
more new enemies than it is killing
actual terrorists or people that are
plotting against the United States there
will be blowback for these policies
there will be blowback and and and you
know what we're giving people a
legitimate reason to want to attack the
United States to avenge the deaths of
their loved ones or the destructions of
their livelihoods and that's a sobering
thing to say as an American or to
realize about your own country and to
realize it because you know after I
heard for the 15th or 20th time someone
in a different country I heard it in
Yemen I heard in Afghanistan I heard it
in Somalia someone say to me I used to
think very differently about the United
States but I see you as the terrorists
now none of us love al-qaeda no none of
us want them in our territory but you
know what we want less than al-qaeda you
and your drones and we're encouraging
people to adopt the mentality of the
enemy of my enemy is my friend and we
ignore the impact of our policy at our
own peril you know I think it's shameful
that in our society the only people that
really have to pay attention to what's
going on abroad in these wars our
military families who have loved ones
deployed in these war zones they think
about it every single day they worry
that that that their son or their
daughter is going to come back in a in a
body bag and they pay attention but many
people in this country just go about
their business you know The Real
Housewives of New York and whatever
Pinot Grigio they're drinking that's
reality television
and then the real widows of Baghdad are
an afterthought if they're even
mentioned at all in the newspapers we
we destroyed Iraq we created a reality
where suicide bombings are a normal part
of daily life in Iraq we built the
largest embassy in the history of
civilization there you know it's it's
it's it's this massive colonial fortress
the CIA is once again ratcheting up its
activities inside of Iraq special
operations teams are returning to Iraq
that war has not ended except now we
have we have the added reality that
there is sectarian violence there's a
constant state of civil war and then you
have the u.s. doing hunting operations
inside the country in Afghanistan as we
draw down the conventional troop
presence you're going to see an
intensification of the operations of
Special Ops teams that are going to
continue to kill their way down the list
we don't even know who we're killing
anymore in Afghanistan we've killed so
many senior commanders of the Taliban
that I wonder how that organization
still exists if you have the ear to
believe the u.s. press releases I don't
know how many times we've killed the
number three man in big Al Qaeda I know
that sigh Adel shiri the number two guy
in al Qaeda in the Arabian Peninsula has
been killed eleven times this year he
was killed a couple of weeks ago right
before he issued an audiotape
referencing current events so you know
when you don't know who you're killing
and and then you're so far down your
kill list that the people that you're
targeting are like local farmers who've
organized uprising against you because
you happen to be in their valley it's
time to really rethink what you're doing
remaining in these countries so it's not
that President Obama is somehow a more
militaristic president than George Bush
Bush and Cheney were engaged in Murder
Inc let's be very clear about it they
were doing unlawful unconscionable
actions every moment of their time in
office
but that's the easy one to oppose what
what is it that President Obama is doing
he is a hawkish Democrat who has doubled
down on a lot of those policies and the
thing that's most damaging about it the
thing that's most damaging about it is
that it actually seemed to have seems to
have stuck as a good idea in the minds
of many liberals I think people will
look back five or 10 years from now and
ask how were we so silent in the face of
a legitimization of policies we opposed
when the Republicans were doing them a
few years earlier for me we crossed a
serious line on September 30th 2011 with
with with how far we've come since the
9/11 attacks when President Obama was
faced with a decision of whether or not
to execute a US citizen who had not been
charged with a crime and against whom no
public evidence had been presented and
this individual was a man named Anwar
Awlaki who was a US citizen born in Las
Cruces New Mexico in 1971 and Obama had
decided that he wanted him taken out and
it was only a matter of choosing the the
time of day and and he didn't waver in
his decision he served as the prosecutor
and the the trial happened through leaks
in the media never in a courtroom he
served as prosecutor judge jury and then
executioner of not just Anwar Awlaki but
the other American citizen who was with
him a young man named Samir Khan now I
don't have any love for Anwar Awlaki I
think Anwar Awlaki said things I found
to be reprehensible he called for the
assassination of a cartoonist in Seattle
Washington named Molly Norris who had
drawn a demeaning picture of the Prophet
Mohammed but he printed an article
saying someone should go and kill her
she had to go underground change her
name you know he praised the the
massacre at Fort Hood Texas
when Nidal Hasan shot up more than a
dozen of his fellow soldiers and wounded
scores of others was paralyzed himself
when he said Nidal Hasan was a hero and
called on other Muslims in the US
military to engage in similar actions
and he had met with the underwear bomber
this this young deranged Nigerian kid
Umar Farouk Abdulmutallab who tried to
set his underpants on fire in the plane
over Detroit on Christmas Day 2009 I'm
willing even for the sake of argument to
concede that everything that every wild
allegation made by anonymous officials
in the press is true about Anwar Awlaki
I don't think it's true but I'm willing
to concede that for the sake of argument
to make this point it's not about who
Anwar Awlaki was or what he did it's
about who are we as a society because
we're we we are not judged no society is
judged by how you treat the popular and
the powerful in your society or
law-abiding citizens you're judged by
how you treat the least of your citizens
the poorest and the most reprehensible
that's what tests how strong your
judicial system is that's what tests
your values so the story of what
happened Anwar Awlaki is very much a
story of what's happening to us but I
want to tell you a little bit about his
story because I think it speaks to where
we are as I said he was born in New
Mexico I remember seeing him on
television soon after 9/11 in fact I
tried to book him I was a producer at
the time for Amy Goodman show Democracy
Now and I remember trying to book him on
that show because he was speaking in a
way that I think he was his voice was
such an important part of the dialogue
that was happening in our country on the
one hand as a as a religious leader in
the Muslim community he was condemning
the 9/11 attacks
he said that al Qaeda had perverted the
religion of Islam and he even said that
the United States had a right to go into
Afghanistan to bring the perpetrators of
9/11 to justice but he also was decrying
and denouncing the hate attacks against
Muslims and the attacks on Muslim
businesses and taxi drivers and and the
rounding up of Muslims for questioning
and the opening of the Guantanamo prison
in Cuba and he was sort of a media
celebrity helping big corporate media
outlets Washington Post New York Times
he was on Talk of the Nation on NPR and
he was on news hour with Jim Lehrer as a
sort of expert in fact he was so he was
so accepted as a part of that discussion
in the US the time that he was invited
by the Pentagon to give a lecture inside
the Pentagon at a luncheon about the
state of Islam in the world and just
give you a sense of how bad the
intelligence was at the time in the
Pentagon among the sandwiches they
served was one that had
bacon on it you invite an imam that come
to the Pentagon and then you serve a
bacon sandwich at his speech
no wonder the WMD thing went so
swimmingly
so Allah Kido was a guy who didn't come
from a radical family his father I know
his his parents are upstanding amazing
people and still are his his dad is one
of the most respected academics in Yemen
he had come to the United States on a
Fulbright scholarship created the
Department of Agricultural engineering
with USAID and American officials in
Yemen and has spent his life trying to
solve the water crisis in that country
they didn't raise Anwar Awlaki to be the
guy that you saw in the YouTube videos
wearing the camouflage jacket and
calling for jihad against the armed
jihad against the United States but he
was a guy who was radicalized by the US
wars abroad and at home and eventually
he leaves the United States and he spent
some time in Britain and then he goes to
Yemen which is his family's ancestral
homeland and he starts recording sermons
and on CDs and audio tapes and his
sermons become very popular in the
english-speaking Diaspora around the
world and then they start to pop up in
terror investigations and the US starts
to become concerned that Anwar Awlaki
that his speeches are going to incite
young Muslims to commit acts of
terrorism in Western countries in
Britain or Canada the United States or
elsewhere in in Europe and and and so
the United States colludes with the
Yemeni regime to arrest Anwar al-awlaki
in 2006 in Yemen on trumped-up charges
that he had intervened in a tribal
dispute and so he's put in prison for 18
months and he spends eight of those 18
months 17 in solitary confinement and I
and the UN the United Nations
investigate his imprisonment said it was
extra legal and that it was clear that
the United States had played a role in
his imprisonment from my reporting I
learned that it was John Negroponte a
who at the time was the Director of
National Intelligence and knows a lot
about dirty wars from his time in
Central America in the 80s where he was
a major player in fueling the Contra war
in Nicaragua and battalion 316 in
Honduras that negroponte a had a meeting
in Washington when El Lackey was in
prison with the with a senior Yemeni
official who was pressing the u.s. to
agree to allow allah key to be released
because if he was coming such a problem
for them and and and so negroponte a
tell
this Yemeni official that the US wants a
Lackey kept in prison for four or five
years so that people forget about him
and that's that's why he remained in
prison he comes out of jail a totally
changed man Italy radicalized and he is
he starts a blog called Imam Anwar blog
and begins taking on discussions about
if suicide bombing is acceptable under
the teachings of the Quran and and and
the u.s. is putting pressure on Yemen to
re-arrest him and eventually our Lackey
goes underground and the head of Yemen's
intelligence service comes to his father
and says in May of 2009 if you don't get
your son to come back into our prison
the Americans are going to kill him in a
drone strike this before the underwear
bomber before Fort Hood before anyone
alleges al Lackey was involved with
anything they still they told his family
if you don't get him back in prison
where he's not charged with any real
crime we mericans are gonna kill him on
a drone strike
so our lackeys father goes and finds him
and he says tells him this and I'll lock
he says what are you an American agent
you're working for them now I was born
free I'll die free I'm not going to let
the Americans tell me which way to
position my head so he leaves his family
his three children and his wife with his
parents and and he goes on the run and
the US tried to kill him more than a
dozen times by my count in one of the
early times that the the u.s. bombing
Yemen in fact the first time the
President Obama authorized a strike on
Yemen they hit a Bedouin village based
on bad intelligence that they had a
senior al Qaeda figure and they killed
14 women and 21 children and it wasn't a
drone strike it was a cruise missile
attack and they used cluster bombs which
are like flying land mines and this
village is called El medulla and when we
were in Avion province rajala was we had
the missile parts videotaped and you can
see clearly they were manufactured by
General Dynamics and they say made in
the United States one of the cluster
bombs that was unexploded went off a
couple days later and blew up more
people and and and the US would have
would have never taken credit for that
strike but for a brave journalist in
Yemen named Abdulelah Haider Shia who
went to the scene and exposed that it
was an American strike he he took
pictures of the missile parts he sent
them to Amnesty International and other
groups they had them analyzed by
munitions
experts who said these are US missiles
not us missiles provided to another
government these are only owned by the
United States what had happened though
in the aftermath of that strike is that
the Yemeni government took
responsibility and issued a press
release saying that the Yemeni Air Force
had attacked an al-qaida base and killed
34 terrorists and then the u.s. sent
congratulations to the Yemeni government
and we know now from the WikiLeaks
cables the general david petraeus what
the time was the commander of CENTCOM
had gone to Yemen and and hatched a
conspiracy with the president of Yemen
to start bombing that country and have
the Yemeni government take
responsibility for the strikes at one
point in one of the meetings according
to the WikiLeaks cables the deputy prime
minister of Yemen jokes with Petraeus I
just lied to the Parliament and told
them that it was our attack and they
laugh about it and the president of
Yemen says you know you can continue to
bomb and as long as we can say the bombs
are ours and not yours and so President
Obama initiates this intense bombing
campaign at times cruise missiles at
times drone strikes at times using
special operations teams on the ground
to unilaterally go and hunt people down
and one of their main targets was Anwar
Awlaki and so Osama bin Laden gets
killed in May of 2011 and then the u.s.
tried to run the deck and they start
intensifying the drone strikes and they
very narrowly miss killing Allah key and
and then a few months later they find
him at a location in northern Yemen
where I started my story and September
30th 2011 they have this choice to make
they found out Lockean while al lockheed
is there his son who has his eldest son
Abdul Rahman who hasn't seen him in
years
is being raised as a normal teenager by
his grandparents there what they're
getting ready they want to send him to
the United States for college he had
just turned 16 years old he's into
hip-hop comic books would go and hang
out and change Square during the Arab
Spring when there was an uprising
against their dictator the kid turns 16
and decides that he wants to see his
father wants to find his father who he
hasn't seen for years and feels that
he's 16 he's crossing a line in life and
so he sneaks into his mother's bedroom
one morning and he goes into her person
steals the equivalent of $40 in yemeni
riyals and he packs a small bag and he
goes to
the bus stop in Babel Yemen in the old
city in sana and he takes a bus to shewe
province where their family's roots are
and the scene of repeated strikes
attempts to kill his father and he goes
there to wait in hopes that his father
will come and find him and while he's
there waiting his father is killed but
he's killed in the north of Yemen
somewhere where the US had never done a
strike before and and and it was sort of
a surprise that our Lackey was there so
he gets killed and after his killing as
I said there was sort of celebration in
Washington one Republican congressman
and said about Samir Khan also being
killed if he wasn't also a target then
it was a bonus it was a twofer and this
this is these two US citizens neither of
whom had been charged with a crime being
killed in an assassination in it in a
direct hit and and you have met
lawmakers celebrating it as this sort of
triumph the only people that said
anything in Washington in opposition to
this were the usual suspects Dennis
Kucinich and Ron Paul they were the only
two people that said anything about it
so while lucky gets killed and and and
then his son is stuck in this village
and there's the uprising going on in the
country and the roads are blocked and as
his grandparents are calling him and
saying your father's dead it's over you
know you have to come back and that they
were raising it and he says yeah I'll
come when soon as the roads clear but I
have to wait for that to happen so he
waits a couple of weeks and then one
night he's out having dinner with his
cousin Achmed it was 17 and and some
other young people from their tribe and
they're sitting in an outdoor restaurant
when a drone appears above them and
fires a Hellfire missile and blows the
kids up and and the Obama administration
has never ever explained why that kid
was killed was he killed because his
last name happened to be al lucky
because no one's ever ever provided any
evidence that that kid had anything to
do with terrorism you know if you look
at his Facebook page and see what his
interests were right up to the moment
that he died the this was a perfectly
normal teenager who appeared to have
nothing in common with his father and
and and this kid is killed with his
teenage cousins and they they after he's
killed a US military official leaks to a
major US paper that he was 21 years old
then the family produces his Colorado
birth certificate showing he had just
turned 16 years old then they said well
he was at an al-qaeda meeting and then
they produced the list of the dead
showing that he was with
as cousins who were all teenagers in
this outdoor restaurant and I said Oh
while he was meeting with ibraheem al
banna who was a propagandist RAL Qaeda
in the Arabian Peninsula ibrahim al
banna is still alive to this day so who
was the target in that strike why was
this kid killed when when Harry Reid was
on CNN the majority leader the senior
Democrat in the Senate when he was on
CNN after these three American citizens
were killed in two-week period in orders
authorized by the Democratic Nobel Peace
Prize winning constitutional law
professor President of the United States
he's on CNN and he's asked by candy
crowley about the killing of these three
american citizens and he said well i'm
not going to talk about classified Intel
but I will say this if there were three
Americans that deserve to be killed it
was those three Americans and so I went
after Harry Reid's office and I was
demanding that they explain what what
habla Rahman Allah he did why did he
deserve to be killed the
sixteen-year-old kid and then Robert
Gibbs who was the former White House
press secretary when he was serving as
the senior surrogate for Obama in the
2012 re-election campaign he was the
chief spokesperson for the campaign he
was asked by a young reporter Sierra
Abramson about the killing of Alba
Rahman Allah key and she said you know
he was killed with no due process is a
American teenager and he said he should
have had a more responsible father there
there are a few things I can think of
that are that are more shameful in life
than blaming the killing of a child on
who their parents are or who their
father was and Robert Gibbs should be
ashamed of himself he shouldn't be able
to appear in public without someone
asking that man why he made that
statement
I met a I don't hang out with powerful
officials I don't get invited to the
White House Correspondents Dinner to
laugh at the president's jokes about
drones the only time that he'll actually
speak about it is when he's done John
Stewart or Google hangout or something
and I don't get invited to the Super
Soaker parties at Joe Biden's house with
Chuck Todd and the boys but but I happen
to run into a former senior official
recently and and I chased him across a
parking lot and true true story and um
and was trying to ask him questions
about this it was someone who was deeply
involved with the kill with the kill
program and overseeing these things and
finally he agreed to talk to me he just
said that you know I I usually don't
make these agreements with powerful
officials but I really want to
understand what happened here he said
I'll talk to you if my name doesn't
appear in your article so I find out
they don't like making that agreement
but I will so I can't tell you who this
was but it was a senior Obama
administration official and he told me
that when President Obama was told that
this kid was killed that he was
extremely upset and that he had been
told the president had been told by the
CIA and the Joint Special Operations
Command that that Ibrahim al banna this
guy I mentioned before was alone and
that that was the target and what was
more interesting is that John Brennan
who now is the CIA director at the time
was the senior adviser on Homeland
Security and counterterrorism that
Brennan believed it was an intentional
hit that either JSOC or the CIA had
intentionally killed that kid perhaps
based on false intelligence and that he
could didn't believe it could possibly
be a coincidence that you killed the
father and then two weeks later you
killed a son and so Brennan ordered a
review and I said to the official so
what happened with your review he goes I
don't know I never saw it and I called
the White House and national security
council and they said they wouldn't
comment to me on and they want to
confirm or deny that there was any
review done and if there was a review
done they wouldn't share with the
findings of the reviewer but then the
official could assure me no no no but
but listen this is all a
misunderstanding I'm sure it was an
outrageous mistake the kid was
collateral damage and I said well that's
your assertion and that's sort of what
the dominant line that they've been
leaking that we they didn't mean to kill
the kid why not say it then like why not
just come forward and say it because it
what it looks like I think to most
people is that you killed the guy's kid
because he was his kid and and I think
it's hard to wrap our heads around how
that could possibly be a coincidence and
he said look at it this way
we had just killed three US citizens in
a two-week period
of whom weren't even targets it didn't
look good it was embarrassing does a
direct quote so the reason they won't
explain why this kid was kills because
it would have been politically
embarrassing for them I mean that's what
what planet are we living on right now
you know I don't care if someone's an
American or or a Yemeni or Pakistani
there should be no difference in our
outrage when innocent people are killed
it doesn't matter what citizenship you
possess but for me the principle is this
if we're willing to do this to our own
citizens if we're willing to cross this
line and deprive our own citizens of
their of the most basic liberties of the
right to respond to your accusers to see
the evidence against you to have a trial
and be judged by a jury of your peers if
we're willing to snatch that away and
say at times well for certain kinds of
people we agree that the mob can grab
the pitchforks and and and they torches
and go and deliver citizens justice then
we should stop saying that we're the
shining city on the hill and that we're
the example for everyone else to follow
we should say we're a country that at
times wants in fact encourages mob
violence or extrajudicial killings
because that's what this is and if we do
it to our own citizens how what are we
going to treat how are we going to treat
Pakistanis or Yemenis or Somalis or
Afghans or Mexicans you know there's
these these are serious questions that
need to be asked of this administration
and the Democrats certainly aren't
asking them it's it's been left to
people like Rand Paul to ask the
questions I mean I my gosh I can't I I
have tried so hard to find something
else I agree with Rand Pollan and I
can't find it but I think Rand Paul
deserves credit for actually asking
those questions that day on the Senate
floor I didn't do the whole I stand with
Rand because I don't stand with Rand I
actually kind of think that it's it's
it's embarrassing that that's who asked
these questions and for a third of that
day for about 30 you know a third of
that 12 14 hour filibuster of John
Brennan's nomination some of the most
sane discussion happened on the floor of
the Senate we're reporting of Glenn
Greenwald and Spencer Ackerman and
people was read into the congressional
record the name Abdul Rahman Allah he
was said multiple times for the first
time you know on c-span and and uh and
and you know in on the on the floor of
the US Senate and then the other
two-thirds of the day was that was a
carnival of crazy just absolute Michele
Bachmann inspire
craziness with all theories about how
Jane Fonda's going to be killed in a
cafe in Berkeley in a drone strike for
supporting the Vietcong and you know the
tea party magazine offices are going to
be bombed in Montana and just pure
craziness and I think part of what we're
having happening here is that you know
you've got on the right people that the
scary black man president is going to
come and drone strike us and that sort
of motivates part of their fear of it
you know Sarah Palin tweeting that she's
against drone strikes yeah if someone
actually makes the horrid mistake of
letting her into power one day she will
be a major lover of drones it's just
because they're Obama's drones she is it
if Obama loves drones they hate drones
so but but but but the point I'm making
here is that we don't have serious
people asking serious questions in
Congress so this stuff goes on
unchallenged and and these guys are
going to look back someday when they try
to challenge this stuff if Jeb Bush is
president or Marco Rubio is president
the Republicans are going to have a
field day with them where were you when
your guy was doing it see I imagine
chill good old Cheney sitting there
fly-fishing somewhere having a nice
little chuckle about the Obama
presidency and saying thank God he
cleaned it up for us because we're going
to be able to continue it the next time
that we come into office I want to I
want to wrap up so that we can have some
discussion and and questions and
interaction here but I want to end by
saying that what what I've seen in the
course of my investigation around the
world over these years is a hellscape
where we have Somali warlords on our
payroll that are being paid to hunt down
people that may or may not be attached
to some militant organization we're
increasing our use of drone strikes we
continue to work with mercenary
companies under the Obama administration
you know the Blackwater is current
iteration academy it's called French
Academy they you know they've rebranded
and they're still on the payroll and
you've got all these Renta armies that
are still operating under President
Obama
backdoor use of secret prisons continued
use of rendition Guantanamo remains open
hunger strikers being force-fed men
who've been cleared for release
languishing in a prison that Obama
pledged six years ago was going to be
shut down in the first year of his
administration how much is actually
changed when it comes to
counterterrorism operations how much is
actually changed when it comes to the
position of the US and the world
you know the u.s. engaged in regime
change in Libya and opened the door for
radical groups that I guarantee you
someday are going to come back around to
hit the United States it's a total
repeat of what happened in Afghanistan
in the 80s where you have the
short-sighted goal of unseating the
Soviets and then you have the long-term
consequence of acts of terrorism against
you from the very people that you
support it at a different point because
it met your short-term strategic
interest someone asked me the other day
about Syria should in the u.s. intervene
to help in Syria we are the least
credible broker in the Middle East right
now second only probably to Israel how
are we going to go and intervene in
Syria when we have destroyed its
neighbor Iraq we are helping along with
the Saudis the Iranians the Qataris and
the Turks we are fueling a sectarian war
in Syria we already have intervened
we've intervened on the side of
instability in Syria we're part of the
problem in Syria right now it's not that
I think Bashar al Assad is is a is a
brutal thug and he was a brutal thug
when he was a convenient ally of the
United States when they were sending
people like Maher Arar to be tortured in
his torture chambers on behalf of the
United States he was a thug then and
he's a thug now but so are these
opposition groups that the US and other
countries are covertly supporting so yet
should we intervene what we already
intervene we need to stop the in-state
destabilizing intervention we're already
doing in the Middle East the final thing
I'll say is this is that we we watched I
think all of us watched these school
shootings with a sense of like utter
horror you know I mean I I sir I
certainly did that
you know when the New York Times ran the
UM the list of the kids killed in the
Newtown shooting you know and you see
those ages 6 6 7 6 6 7 I mean it just
crushes you it guts you as a person and
the reason it does and is because
journalists actually did their job and
told us the stories of of heroism of
teachers who tried to save those kids
lives you know I mean the story sticks
with me of those three kids who were
hiding in the closet and all of us
remember I'm sure some story from it or
the Boston Marathon bombing you know
watching Carlos Arredondo who lost his
son in in Iraq you know he runs toward
the blast and there's that iconic
picture of him if you don't know his
name I'm guarantee you've seen his face
he had the cowboy hat on and he was
carrying the double amputee and I needed
to he had tied a
cloth around his leg to try to stop the
bleeding and that the adorable eight
year old kid in the picture that went
viral on Facebook that he had drawn you
know a short time before he was killed
that day you know calling for peace and
there was a graduate student that was
killed in the Boston Marathon bombing
and then another one who was from China
and and recently when I was in Boston I
was with a friend who's Chinese and she
was telling me that uh she said you know
the President Obama named said that
woman's name and it was a big story in
China and I said oh really and she said
yeah and there was a blog post that went
viral in China and the title of the blog
post was where you died matters and the
point of it the point of it was that the
most powerful man in the world never
would have mentioned that woman's name
if she had died in a factory explosion
making a product for American consumers
she her name was mentioned her death
mattered and her life now matters
because we know who she was because of
where she died and and but I think there
are lessons to be to be drawn from from
this if we as journalists did our job
and and stop referring to people as
collateral damage or casualties and and
and we actually knew the stories of the
the little girls in L medulla whose
families were wiped out when President
Obama authorized a cruise missile attack
on their village if we knew that if we
saw their artwork that they had done
before before their parents were taken
away from them or if we knew the the
stories of families that have been
destroyed in in our drone strikes
livelihoods wipe wiped out then it's
harder to sort of dehumanize the other
and say oh well there's only a few
civilians being killed or these are
these are surgical this is a cleaner way
of waging war one it wouldn't be
possible we can be an incredibly
empathetic society as Americans and we
show our best side in crisis and it's
true it really is true in those school
shootings it's there is a sense of
community we walk around and we all are
sharing a common experience because we
consider it our own but we have a moral
obligation as residents or citizens of
the most powerful nation on earth to to
own some part of what happens on the
other side of the of our missiles
because it's being done in our names
it's being done with our money and it's
ultimately going to affect our stability
so our challenge is actually quite a
simple one but
it's a bold move to make in life it's to
have empathy for people who don't reside
next door to us or don't appear on our
newscast to make it our business to know
the name and story of one person who's
lost something in this war so that the
next time someone tries to use the
phrase collateral damage or casualties
you have a real story to tell them and
that's our challenge thank you very much
thank you for that
there are microphones here thank you
there are microphones here and I think
that the policy is that people just come
up or to the or do you better bring your
in a pet play Phil Donahue yeah okay
this yeah this young man over here if we
could try to have some gender balance to
a lot of men always raise their hand
first okay uh thirty seconds real quick
so over the past week we've learned that
two news networks have succumbed to
mounting pressures that are politically
powerful and financially wealthy al
Jazeera took down an op-ed written by a
professor who writes frequently about
israeli-palestinian issues and PBS or a
PBS affiliate reneged on a decision to
air a documentary that was critical of
the koch brothers and while media
companies bowing to political pressures
isn't necessarily new news what concerns
me about these cases is that these are
networks that have traditionally been
thought of as independent and fearless
in the coverage that they provide and if
these pressures are mounting against
them are they also mounting against
journalists who are truly independent in
every sense of the word journalists such
as yourself Glenn Greenwald and Amy
Goodman and if so what have you done or
what can we do to help you maintain your
independence because the work that you
do is truly is a gem and we should help
you yeah thank you for raising that I
mean I um I think that the the White
House and the Justice Department war on
journalism which is really what it is is
reprehensible I think that the targeting
of The Associated Press and and the
seizure of their phone records they did
a wide sweep against them they're trying
to say that it's about one story that
they did about divulging classified
information about an alleged underwear
bomb plot in Yemen a year or so ago it
actually was a part of a much larger
hunt against The Associated Press
they've done some of the best reporting
on the CIA and the and the widening
covert wars Adam Goldman and Matt Apuzzo
and Kim Dozier the reporters that are
covering this to the Associated Press
are top notch reporters
these are reporters for corporate news
outlet but they are top notch or major
powerful news outlet and they are top
notch reporters and I think that they
were targeted because they were getting
too close to story
that the White House did not want out in
the public domain and what they were
doing was what journalists are supposed
to be doing that when you have official
leaks you know there's wiki leaks and
then there's White House leaks and White
House leaks is is what they want you to
be told because it fits their political
agenda and you know John Brennan is a
major leaker he's responsible for so
much BS that was floated after the bin
Laden raid he had to retract almost
everything that man said because it was
false but journalists are taken for a
ride every day by this White House and
those that are independent and ask
questions their emails are being
intercepted they're their Internet
service providers are being served with
National Security Letters their phone
records are being seized you know I
don't have any love in my heart for Fox
News but what they did to this reporter
James Rosen is shameful where they tried
to criminalize the process of being an
actual reporter this has sent a chill
through the journalism community and the
relatively small world of reporters that
cover these national security issues it
used to be the case that I would use
encrypted email and an OTR software off
the record software to have encrypted
chats with sources no one will touch it
anymore
they say I'm talking with sources within
government encryptions are even broken
not safe I won't do it
you bet we basically have to be Luddites
now in order to communicate with our
sources because no one wants to leave a
digital footprint no one wants to
communicate in in that way it used to be
that they would have someone break into
the offices of a reporter now I say they
just they'll hack your email or they'll
they'll get a they'll get a warrant and
they'll go and take it you may or may
not find out years later when you take
that and combine it with the war on
whistleblowers you know people like
Thomas Drake who was an NSA official who
blew the whistle on criminality during
the Bush era the Obama just Department
went after him and and and and tried and
ruin his career that man works at an
Apple Store right now he used to be one
of the top people at the NSA working on
sensitive programs he's now working at
an Apple Store there's nothing wrong
with someone working an Apple store to
make a living but this man had his
career ruined because he stood up and
blew the whistle and provided
information to the press that he
believed the American people had a right
to know because he thought that it was
criminal when you when you take the war
on journalism and the war on
whistleblowers and you put it together
and you look at how John Kiriakou the
former CIA operative is in prison right
now in part for blowing the whistle on
torture while Jose Rodriguez who was one
of the architects of the torture program
is on a book tour that says a lot about
where we are
in this country this look forward not
backwards stuff I'm going to try that
the next time you get stopped for
speeding Oh officer I was just look
forward and not backward or where I came
from but it's it's chilling what you're
saying and I think there's
self-censorship that goes on and in the
case of the Koch brothers I mean money
talks I mean those that they are they
are an incredibly powerful nefarious
force in our society right now involved
with all sorts of badness I mean it's it
I don't know how else to put it with the
Koch brothers their tentacles that reach
into almost every anti-democratic plot
going on in this country yeah
sorry yeah this is what I would said if
we go to a young woman for yeah just
auradon it just have to be young it
could be any woman I'm just saying is it
all right so I didn't call me honest all
right it's all right sorry yeah yeah you
qualify it's all right so I'm not be
trying to be ageist here thank you
um my question was as I'm listening to
your talk and I listen to everything
that you're talking about and everything
that we've seen happen with our
constitutionally trained constitutional
era president continuing these terrible
Bush policy I got that from a wu-tang's
song well done no no um it's very easy
to be filled with a sense of despair
because I mean our political leaders our
political leadership in this country is
entirely bought and sold the
military-industrial complex is
completely off the rails and we have a
populace that just happily handed over
our civil rights with a Patriot Act
starting there and continuing and so my
question to you is in your work and in
your research have you been able to draw
any conclusions about I mean are there
any points of vulnerability left in this
this the system this machine where it
can be attacked because I don't feel
like we can go to our legislators and
argue for change any more I'm curious to
hear what you think soft points are look
yeah thank you for that I mean I I don't
think anything will ever fundamentally
change in our society unless we confront
and expel corporations from the
electoral process from from dominating
you know members of Congress served
two-year terms they probably spend 18 to
20 months of those two year terms
raising funds and and and who are the
biggest donors you know if you look at
sort of a remarkable study when you look
at what the way the defense industry
spends its dollars I bet a lot of people
just assume they give most of their
money to Republicans no no no when that
winds are blowing the Democratic
direction then they give more money to
the Democrats and they do the
Republicans and so you have a situation
where I mean it is there they literally
are bought you know I had I was talking
to a friend from a different country
recently and we we were at a gathering
with Nancy Pelosi and this friends from
I'm not going to say who he is because
of what I would tell you next but he
said to me you know I want Nancy Pelosi
to see your movie I'm like Nancy Pelosi
not gonna see our movie and he goes well
what if we raised a hundred thousand
dollars and paid her to watch the movie
and he goes we could do that in my
country we could figure out a way to get
the president to go and do it and I said
oh you don't know you're you know the
corruption here is actually formalized
you know it's a it's it's like we can do
we could give it to her campaign we
can't actually pay her but we could so
we could actually do that track because
in thinking about it you know I probably
could give $100,000 to Nancy Pelosi to
watch the movie I would just have to
donate it to her PAC or something but
but that's the point that's how our
system is set up and so when you have
politicians that that can get get
bankrolled by huge defense contractors
or big oil or big energy what incentive
do they have to have a conscience on
those issues they're no longer
representing their constituents they're
representing their paymasters and so you
know the best chance we had to even
start to chisel away at this was
mccain-feingold you know the legislation
on campaign finance reform and it wasn't
perfect but it would have been a step
toward it when Obama opted out of the of
public funding and went nuclear with the
private cash it basically destroyed it
and and then McCain was forced to to to
then go toe to toe with the private
money fundraising against Obama and that
pretty much crushed it so I mean I do
think that some segments of our society
has to make it their business to try to
change that aspect of how politics are
done because all the rest of it is just
sort of speeches that we're giving and
pressure because writing letters to
members of Congress on these issues
seldom tilts them in any way it's money
that talks and and and money runs the
system and so it is a bleak outlook and
I don't
I don't mean to like be passing out
razor blades but I do think that it is a
bleak situation yeah we'll just switch
back and forth we can your go ahead
whichever you talked about the military
drones but there's also illegal drones
being used against a Muslim man in this
country like the four tix five which is
probably one of the most egregious cases
of these five hundred
Muslim men in prison now where they use
undercover agent provocateurs they use a
lot of legal or on the armed secret
testimony and these are kangaroo courts
here in the United States in New Jersey
with the person who's now governor of
New Jersey who was the district attorney
that prosecuted the vortex five there's
been many articles written about how all
these cases are unjust and they
hearkened back to the jailing
imprisoning of the Japanese during World
War two
is there a question that you're getting
to yeah I'm familiar with all those
cases but yes yeah don't you think that
that's also unjust as unjust as using
drones overseas it's also I'm just
hearing neither
okay yeah the FBI is shown very adaptive
breaking up its own terror plots
I mean it's happened repeatedly it's a
no but I'm saying that seriously I mean
there's there's a pattern here where you
know and and sometimes it's they target
mentally really unstable individuals and
they tap into that instability and and
there's a number of cases where the
individuals who are will go to prison
for a long time actually are are people
who have serious mental challenges and
and the FBI will infiltrate in it and in
some of these cases they actually seem
to be the ones encouraging them to you
know plot an actual bomb attack maybe it
was people who were contemplating some
action or that they were becoming
radicalized and then you have an FBI
informant who
pops onto the scene and next thing you
know they have an actual plot under way
and and they are they're setting people
up and part of it is you know they're
creating this climate of fear there's a
demand for results but absolutely what's
happening at home is deeply connected to
what's going on abroad and and there
have been so many Muslims that have been
railroaded in this country and demonized
and and set up it's not that there
aren't active terror plots there are and
I hope we do bust them up but we
shouldn't be breaking up our own terror
plots I mean that says something really
dark about about what's going on with
law enforcement I also it tangentially
relates to what you're saying I'm very
concerned about the paramilitaries a
ssin of law enforcement in the u.s. it's
a serious concern where you have you
know there's part of the issue is about
domestic use of drones and a number of
municipalities there are citizens that
are getting together and trying to ban
the use of drones but it's it's much
deeper than that it's it's we have
police are becoming paramilitary forces
and you have this sort of the wars in
Iraq and Afghanistan are coming home and
you know everything is sort of moving
toward SWAT style tactics I mean look at
you know in in Boston and when they were
hunting down this this cop
Dornan are out and in Los Angeles I mean
this looks like Special Operations raids
that are happening and you know
certainly in poor communities and
communities of color across this country
people have been facing this reality for
for years and years where urban areas in
the United States are effectively war
zones and night raids are a part of
daily life just as they are in Kandahar
Afghanistan and and you know we when you
combine that with the privatization of
certain law enforcement functions and a
para militarization of the us-mexico
border ever we're doing everything is
being militarized this tsarnayev kid in
boston you know who's in custody in
connection with the Marathon bombing
some of the Republicans wanted him
treated as an enemy combatant they want
him sent to Guantanamo despite the fact
that he's a US citizen there's this this
knee-jerk military reaction to things to
crises and and and that's something we
really have to confront in our society
but it's it's it really threatens our
democratic existence I think when
everything becomes a paramilitary
solution it's it's very very
serious problem yeah we go to the other
side yeah you just you pick someone
because I can't see what the lights but
we should also make sure make an effort
to get back to the back - Thank You mr.
Scotto for speaking today I was
wondering I heard a report this morning
that the CIA has said it at least says
it's going to transfer its drone program
to the Pentagon yeah I heard that on
Democracy Now this morning and I was
wondering that the lack of a public
explanation which Obama says he will
give about the drone program whether to
what extent that's covering up
internecine struggles and turf wars with
between the CIA and the Pentagon for
instance in the White House and to what
extent it's just I think as other
questions have said a war machine that
no longer considers itself to be bound
by even vaguely by the rule of law right
so you're referring to this has been
talked about for some time it's sort of
I mean really in reality what I think is
that this is sort of a dog and pony show
that John Brennan you know they talk
about John Brennan like he's a priest
you know they compare
he's like st. Augustine and he's just
toiling over I mean this if you could go
and look into this later it's incredible
like they're all these articles talking
about how he and Obama are basically
like these these monks you know running
the drone program and and Brennan you
know and so Brennan part of the sort of
dog and pony show is Brennan
of course Brennan couldn't become CIA
director when Obama first tried to
nominate him because Democrats actually
stood up and said we don't want a guy
who prays torture to be Obama's director
of CIA and then years later it's just
Rand Paul and the crazy parade opposing
him which shows you how far we've come
and then Brennan saying well we're going
to move the drone program over to the
military because there's greater
transparency the whole thing first of
all the military has been running a
parallel drone program for the duration
of you know what's been called the war
on terror in Pakistan JSOC the Joint
Special Operations Command operates
drones and Yemen they already operate
drones so it's it's it's intended to
sort of give the perception that
something is being done that they're
listening to the public but in reality
it's it's it's going to be it's going to
continue business as usual some people
are under the misperception that the
military cannot do a covert action that
it's only the CIA JSOC does covert
actions every day around the globe so
you know I'm not saying that it's it's
it's not quite that it's that makes you
know no difference whatsoever I actually
think it could make it worse have less
oversight you know there are there are
some actual tough questioners on the
Intelligence Committee in the house the
Senate Armed Services Committee on these
issues has largely been a rubber-stamp
operation for these covert actions so
you know I think part I think I think
really it's kind of propaganda it's
meant to make it look like something's
happening when in reality it's just a
you know old wine in a new bottle yeah
in the back at Dustin hi Jeremy thanks
for coming um I I really respect you a
lot I've been listening to your work and
reading your articles but um I wouldn't
be doing my job as a human being if I
didn't correct you on your word for
weight because I certainly didn't bomb
Anwar and I will lucky I didn't send any
of these drones over to Pakistan so
respectfully I'd like to correct you on
that so you're a tax resistor well I'm
certainly an aggressive military
resistor modem but you're so you don't
pay taxes I'm working on it okay but
you're gonna confront me about my use of
the word we you know why I use well let
me defend myself that why I use the word
we' is I think if we don't all realize
that we're it we're complicit in this
then then we're we're whistling past the
graveyard we are deeply complicit in
this I respect that
I respect that
but I admire your spirit man I
appreciate that good stuff what woke you
up to this look see by the way Pierce's
see his teachers is not a terrorist I'm
glad you clarified that for the record
Nux it can someone remove him for asking
me a tough question
I always love that what officials do
that when someone like disrupts their
speech then they say you know it is the
First Amendment great now the exits
right there to throw him out
look I you said what woke me up to this
I mean you know I
I remember hearing Amy Goodman on the
radio for the first time and I I'd
wanted to be a teacher I was that's what
I was studying I've never taken a
journalism class in my life and I heard
Amy Goodman on the radio and I said I
want to I want to do that and so I
started stalking her and I in a
non-creepy way you know but I started
writing her letters and asking if I
could if she had a cat I'll feed their
cat or walk her dog or wash her windows
and she eventually had to like decide
whether to get a restraining order
against me or like let me come and
volunteer so I started off and radio and
learned it like as a trade as an
apprentice like the way a plumber
electrician and and my early work what I
started off doing well you know one of
the first trips I took was to Iraq in
the 90s I went in with this group called
voices in the wilderness which is now
called voices for creative non-violence
and they were symbolically breaking the
sanctions on Iraq by bringing in medical
supplies that had been banned by the US
you know from from bringing into Iraq
and and just it opened my eyes I
couldn't believe what was being done in
our name and I wasn't an investigative
reporter at all I was a kid with a with
a tape recorder and what much of what I
did was just go and ask people to tell
me their stories and then I tried to
edit it into cogent narrative so we
could say well here's this person this
mother who's in a hospital in Basra and
she's just given birth to a baby that
has a gaping hole that stretches from
nose to the throat and the doctors are
saying that it's a result of the
munitions that were used during the Gulf
War that had depleted uranium in them
and so much of my early work as a
journalist was about listening to people
who lived on the other side of the
barrel of the gun and I I never looked
back they said that's what I wanted to
do and I felt like it was it was it was
so important for people in this country
to have have names and faces on the
other side of the of the story and and
that's what's driven me I mean and
there's so many people that I think
about every day that I met along the way
that humbled me and the journalists who
I told you about that exposed that u.s.
missile strike Abdulelah Haider Shia
he's in prison in Yemen right now in
part because President Obama is keeping
them him there he was convicted on
trumped-up charges of being a member
al Qaeda in a court set up by the
dictator of Yemen to prosecute
journalists for crimes against the state
and and and when the president of Yemen
was going to pardon him news leaked in
the Yemeni media that this was going to
happen and President Obama that day
called the dictator of Yemen he
personally called him and said that the
US wants him to remain in prison and
that journalist he's been in prison for
three years and he was a well-known
journalist who worked who did work for
The Washington Post ABC News al-jazeera
and was a fiercely independent guy who
was very critical of al Qaeda and did
tough interviews with the leaders of Al
Qaeda he was a real journalist he's in
prison because of our constitutional law
professor president and you know so you
ask me why I do what I do I mean I might
if you look at my book my book is
dedicated to journalists imprisoned for
telling the truth and those who die in
pursuit of the truth and and then the
last line in my book is that Abdul Allah
Haider Shia this Yemeni journalist
should be set free and and so I mean I I
try to do my work in the spirit of
unfamous journalists who don't get
invited to give speeches that are
broadcast on c-span or don't get to go
on the Rachel Maddow Show or whatever
that those are those are those are my
heroes the people that keep me going
I have a quick question with probably a
long answer can you tell us something
about what your investigations have
shown as to Israel's involvement in
dirty wars drone wars I'm either as a
model or as you know a producer of
drones and so on yeah I mean I mean
Israel was a trendsetter with this for
the u.s. I mean the the you know the
Israelis Raley's the Israeli model you
know with these these assassination ops
really is what the u.s. based its
program on and you know Israel the
United States are deep in bed together
in all sorts of covert actions around
the world of course the u.s. you know
gives tremendous military support to the
Israelis I would recommend that that
people watch this film if you haven't
seen it called the gatekeepers which is
the interviews with former heads of the
Shin Bet and I mean it's a flawed movie
but it's an important movie and I think
it's definitely worth seeing where these
guys describe sort of the the people
that were running the kill program in
Israel kind of describe how they saw it
playing out and what the actual you know
end result of it has been and there's
some pretty sobering remarks that they
make in that but you know I mean Israel
and the fact that it possesses hundreds
of nuclear weapons that you know no
one's allowed to talk about when when
someone when a scientist Mordechai
Vanunu blew the whistle on the nuclear
program they put them in prison and
drove him insane you know and the United
States won't ever talk about Israel's
nuclear program there's a reason why
other countries in that region want
nuclear weapons it's as a deterrence
against Israel you know and and and I I
think if there's going to be an attack
on Iran it's going to be an Israeli LED
attack I think there's a lot of reason
to suspect that Israel has been involved
with the assassination of the Iranian
nuclear scientists I don't know that
anything has been definitively proven
but someone's certainly killing Iranian
nuclear scientists and and and Israel
certainly that has had taken the most
belligerent stance toward Iran so you
know Israel is engaged in its own dirty
Wars it doesn't even need the United
States to tell it what to do it
certainly is deep into its own actions
yeah oh really okay well let me just say
I'm happy to when even if people don't
want to buy a book I'm when I do the
books I'm happy to talk to people you
just have to get in line with everyone
else but I'd be happy to if you didn't
get a chance to
your question too to do it so I don't I
don't know where my fill and Philippe
Philippe Donna Donahue are but they can
good yeah I feel that
the people that came here today are
equally outraged by what you've reported
but I also sense that not many people
are surprised because we've been
inundated with reports of as someone
else someone else mentioned earlier the
military-industrial complex abusing
their powers and extensions of that so
my question to you is looking on the
legacy of Oliver Stone and other people
before you have tried to blow the
whistle do you really feel that it's an
issue of information that's not getting
out or do we just need experts like you
to actually run for political office to
make change no how do you mean do you
not on your life rather yeah that ivory
I appreciate the question um no I way
too many skeletons of I closet they
would not know I mean look to take your
question seriously um I you know I I do
think that unless we break the duopoly
you know unless we have an actual
multi-party system in this country we're
not going to get anywhere with the
Democratic and Republican parties I mean
their their agenda is to support big
business and and and to keep sort of the
idea that America is the exception in
the world that that's a requirement to
be president in the United States so you
know I I think I really admire people
particularly on a local level who try to
organize third party challenges to
Democrats and Republicans because I
think it's it's the most democratic
thing you could do is to try to fight
actually to break the stranglehold that
the two parties have particularly when
it comes to the national security state
you know there are differences in
domestic policy between Democrats and
Republicans when it comes to the
national security state they are there
the war party period and and so I mean
I'm glad you raised it and maybe there's
young people in this room that are going
to try to run for those offices and get
involved at the school board level City
Council level because I actually think
it could that you can have changes or
that and confronting corporate money
those aren't the issues that
I cover but those are the issues that I
care about personally as someone in this
country and in my personal life those
are issues that I work on and along with
trying to end the death penalty so I
thank you all very much for coming thank
you for your question
happy to answer questions we'll go
upstairs
you